and women evolved man you got to take
that you got to take that man women
evolve and a good Predator a good apex
predator
a good apex predator evolves as they're
out there out there in the jungle Yeah
man they got to survive
women have to survive
and just think about this just think
about this women
don't get physical mostly in our society
like think about since 200 000 years
you'd be surprised I've been well
attacked you've been well attacked right
right but typically to survive they've
been able to get underneath survival uh
mechanisms which would be either
government men cavemen uh shelters
they've been able to do this and survive
they're still here I mean in any sense
of the imagination if they all had to
get physical they'd be dead
if there was no transactional
relationship between men and women there
would be no women but obviously there
would be no species right so with that
being said women are survivalists
and they will do things to survive even
use love
as a means for survival
think about this think about this the
first cave woman
you know she might have had a nice rack
or a pretty face or something like that
right and she and she figured out
there's a saber-toothed tiger out there
gnawing on my ass
do I want to keep running every day
or I do I want to go to the guy that got
the cave up up at the top of the
mountain the cave yeah yeah
I'm kind of afraid of tigers
no right right yeah
so what you gonna do I love you caveman
and by the way you can have access to
all this down here if you want that's
what you like I'll be up in the cave
yeah yeah okay yeah I could see that
that's yeah right so that's a form of
manipulation okay but it's a
manipulative tactic not against the man
it's uh to survive okay so you think
like at our base we're manipulative
women
men and women are but we're also
participating in a transactional
relationship right so when I say
manipulation manipulation doesn't mean
bad
manipulation is just manipulation
whatever you got to do to survive like
for me I gotta go out there and become
you know a good mover of stones and
build that's manipulation and then I'm
also going to say I'm gonna get I'm
gonna be the man with the cave with at
the highest mountain so I can't get the
best hey [ __ ] or whatever you know what
I mean like I'm I want the best woman I
want the best cave woman my cave is at
the top you never have to run from a
tiger
that's manipulation
otherwise look look if I don't need no
cave women I wouldn't make a cave at the
top of the mountain okay but I when I
think of manipulation right I think of
something being like dishonest about it
do you know what I'm saying that's how
we've been told yes and maybe maybe I'm
incorrect so maybe I've been using the
word incorrectly that's possible but
when I think of manipulation I think of
like I think it's manipulative to lie
about your body count
I think that's manipulated sure it is
yeah but absolutely yeah but I think
it's not manipulative if a guy is just
like you become the biggest strongest
fastest and then caveman you know right
but manipulation sometimes like you can
just handle something that's called
manipulation I'm manipulating this thing
right I'm not doing something evil to it
I'm not using something against somebody
else I'm just manipulating it when I
think of that term like I think if some
things did so if I had the equivalent it
would be like a guy lying about his
money that would be a manipulative
tactic yeah yeah yeah yeah right and
people use that
and they use that all the time
yeah but I would think
I guess I would I don't think like a guy
to like build him out
himself up to be the best guy he could
be I wouldn't think of that as
manipulation I could be wrong oh I see
what you're saying so you're saying
you're saying it's always got to be
accompanied by a lie manipulation and
lie is synonymous I don't think it'd be
synonymous I think they're basically
we're misusing the word right and that's
because we have a negative connotation
to manipulation but
but what I'm saying is what what we're
doing is transacting
we're transacting but the manipulative
part is somebody convincing us we're
doing that I love
oh that's the manipulation because look
check this out
I love you so I provide for you okay yes
so you love me so you work so hard in
life to provide what if you didn't have
access to me would you have worked so
hard
probably not like if I knew I wasn't
going to get no women I'd probably be
like what's the point that's what a lot
of guys are doing now what's the point
of going out there and trying to date
because look at what what I'm getting
I'm getting Hoes Got peeling skeezers
and whatnot right so check this out
for women
for women if they don't use love yeah
we're good I just check it every now and
then it's good though it's good okay if
if women don't use love how do they
transact how do they get the
relationship
if we don't use the sex
yeah okay but or you know they used to
have like um finishing schools finishing
schools so she could be the best woman
she could be to provide something in
excess right now it's just sex I would
say for most for most women which is
dumb but but you know there's cooking
cleaning you know yeah I mean those
things are should be outsourced those
are outsourced now because women want
careers I'll tell you man I tell you
women typically have fumbled the best
opportunity in the history of life and I
think young women are figuring it out
and that opportunity is they had a
better situation they were convinced
that they could get a better situation
many of them are finding out they're not
as happy as they thought they would be
pursuing careers and job they end up
going why am I at work I could have laid
on my back for my husband and did these
other things to fill in the void cooking
cleaning and child raising and all these
things which you know
women don't cook very well but that's
neither here nor there they're not the
best cooks neither the best cleaners but
that's what they had to use to transact
a relationship
this is all transactional yeah
people think there's some feeling
involved with it but the feeling yes
there is feeling but that's not going to
last long like two years it's gonna last
two years and then you're gonna say
loyalty time commitment like those are
the things that make a relationship
so when people say well what about love
go have some love I mean but it's not
gonna lie as a man that's known that
part is if you base your relationship
do you think men and women love
differently absolutely yeah how so well
here's the thing women women want to be
loved a certain way and women uh men
just want to be loved
right so women want to dictate how
they're loved
and men just want to be loved so women
are the receivers of love that's what I
this is what I believe and in turn the
woman gives respect back to the man
however that's not what we're doing
today that's what's messing up the
marketplace so women want to dictate how
they want to be low let me explain that
so I can provide Love to You by
displaying it by demonstrating it I can
support you I can come home to you every
night I can make sure I only have
children with you I can make sure I
don't embarrass you and have other women
out here in their neighborhood I'm not
screwing the whole neighborhood of women
and embarrassing you right I provide for
you
I I bring everything that I do out in
society I I do I do for you
that's love as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and
to monetize on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible